[Michael Curry]  Everybody thought home
computers were a really, really cool thing
that only nerdy people
were ever gonna be into...
3D printers are on that same kind of arc.
We're out to fuel
the next industrial revolution...
by putting the power to manufacture things
in your hands.
[Barack Obama]  3D printing
has the potential
to revolutionize
the way we make almost everything.
Some of the developments
that come from the 3D printer
might put the first person
to create that device
on the pedestal of
"major social innovator."
Every day, I get inspired by people
who have MakerBots
and are doing amazing things.
[Chuck Pettis]  He grew up in
an entrepreneurial household.
So he saw things getting produced.
[Jeff Osborn]  People who run
successful, small technology companies...
pretty much have to be crazy.
When we started, we were the only one.
Now we've got the big guys
and then we've got lots of small guys
that think we're the big guys.
Formlabs basically started...
in the basement of the house
that David and I were living in.
I thought, "This is a quintessential geek
we are bringing up."
Obsessed with what he is doing.
[Brad Feld]  If you're a leader,
every day there is something new
that comes up and smacks you in the face.
[Cody Wilson]  Welcome to the age
of the printed magazine.
I'm gonna introduce you to
one of the most dangerous men on Earth.
[Cody Wilson]  We're
information anarchists.
There should be one law.
If the police can have it,
if the military can have it,
then you can have it.
[Anthony Moschella]  Somebody gets murdered
with a MakerBoted handgun...
Then what happens?
[Osborn]  His iron rule, we don't talk
about 3D printed guns. Period.
We didn't have to say,
"This is our response to the gun thing."
It was just, "Hey, look at this."
[Brad Kenney]  Robohand was
worth talking about.
Did it get half the pick-up
of the DEFCAD stuff?
Controversy sells.
We were all inventing
what was gonna come next.
[Feld]  A great partner
will turn into a horrible enemy.
A company you've never heard of before
will come out with something
that changes the game.
[Steve Jobs]  Every once in a while,
a revolutionary product comes along
that changes everything.